Charlie 053
simultaneous approach runway runway
aircraft calling safe position.
Anytime we depart or arrive at an
airfield, we need to obtain the current
weather information. And this allows us
to pick the correct runway, set the
correct altimeter setting, calculate the
performance of our aircraft, and know if
we can legally fly VFR into the field.
Now, we could just ask ATC for this
information, but it kind of clogs up the
radio and makes their job even harder.
And trust me, you want those guys to be
focused on helping you avoid hitting
other airplanes. So because of that, we
have automated weather reporting
frequencies we can listen to before we
go talk to ATC or fly into that
untwowered airfield. The first one of
these is ADIS and that stands for
automated terminal information service.
You'll usually find this at bigger
airfields like class bravo, class
Charlie, and some class delta airfields.
As you can see on this VFR sectional, we
could listen to that ADIS report by
tuning in this frequency right here on
one of our con radios. Let's listen in
and see what the weather is over at
Witchah airport. Turn point is Charlie
053 Zulu 1 8 08 visibility 1 0 sky clear
temperature - 7 - 1 2 altimeter 3034
simultaneous visual approach new line of
runway one n left runway one right
notice here that every ADIS message is
designated with a letter and a time that
it was produced and this allows you to
determine if you have the most
up-to-date weather. New recordings are
usually produced every hour, and these
are usually prepared by a human being
every 45 to 50 minutes after the hour.
And they'll produce more of these if the
weather's changing rapidly. That way,
you have the most up-to-date weather
information. And that's pretty handy to
know because if the current time is 0150
Zulu, then you know this information
came out almost an hour ago and Delta
should be coming out really soon. And
when I contact air traffic control, I
tell them I have information Charlie and
now they know exactly which weather
information I have. And this is what
that might sound like.
Wita approach Skyhawk 1234 Papa 25
nautical miles west of the field 3500
inbound with Charlie.
And now approach knows that I have
information Charlie at the field. And if
that's not the most current, they should
tell you.
Skyhawk 1 2 3 4 Papa approach radar
contact 24 nautical miles west of the
field information delta now current
altimeter 3035.
As you can see in his reply, he let us
know that Delta is the most current ADIS
at the field. And that's no problem.
We'll just listen to the ADIS frequency
on our backup radio and then we'll let
him know once we have it. Now, there's
probably going to be some times when you
come into the field and there's no ADIS
available. If that happens, you can make
a radio call like this.
Approach Skyhawk 1 2 3 4 Papa 25
nautical miles west of the field 3,500
inbound with negative8s. Now, if you
make this radio call, be ready because
he's about to give you a bunch of
information. But the weather information
that he gives you should be in the same
format as the ADIS broadcast. And right
now, you're probably thinking, well,
I'll just get the weather myself by
looking it up on ForeFlight. And while
that's an excellent idea, and
ForeFlight's an awesome tool, the
weather you see there doesn't always
match perfectly with the ADIS
observation. And because of that,
anytime the ADIS is available, that's
what you should use. But if it's not and
you have forflight at your disposal,
this is the radio call you could make
instead.
Wita approach Skyhawk 1 2 3 4 Papa 25
nautical miles west 3,500 inbound with
the numbers. [clears throat]
When you use this phrase with the
numbers, that tells him that you have
the weather, but you don't specifically
have the AIS. You should never use this
phrase to let ATC know that you have the
AIS. Only when you have the partial
weather from like ForeFlight or some
other source. And by telling him this,
he doesn't have to give us the entire
weather observation, just what he feels
is important. That being said, I want to
show you one thing that's available at
some airports across the US. At this
airfield, there's an extra tab in
forflight labeled D8. As you can see
here, they're showing information mic
and it's all the weather information
that you need to come in for a landing.
If that doesn't get you stoked about the
future, I don't know what will. Let's go
back and take a closer look at the ADIS
broadcast. Now, I don't want to insult
your intelligence, but I just want to
read through this real quick. As you can
see, the winds are 180 at 8 knots. The
visibility is 10 statute miles and the
sky is clear. But sometimes you'll
listen to the ADIS and there won't be a
ceiling and visibility reading. And this
sometimes happens when the ceilings are
greater than 5,000 ft AGL and the
visibility is greater than 5 statute
miles. And sometimes you'll hear this
weird phrase, Calav. Okay. And don't
worry, that's not talking about Farmer
John's baby cows. That's just letting
you know that the ceiling and visibility
is better than 505. All right, back to
the reading. As you can see, we've got a
temperature of -7, a due point of -12,
altimeter is 3034, and that altimeter
setting might be the most important part
of this broadcast. Make sure you reset
your altimeter as soon as you hear that.
And as you can see, runway 1 nine left
and one nine right are both in use right
now. One more thing to note about the
ADIS broadcast is that it may also
include NOTMS. Now, you should have
checked these prior to flight, but it
doesn't hurt to listen to them again on
the ADIS broadcast just in case
something new popped up.
14 closed
runway one nit
bravo runway exits available in Bravo
service. Multiple tanks closures.
Before we talk about the last two
automated weather services, let's talk
about three things you need to keep in
mind when you're thinking about ADIs.
First, it's used at high activity
airfields. Airfields that are a little
less busy will typically use AWAS and
ASOS, and some might not even have a
weather reporting service. Also, you
need to remember that the recordings are
constantly broadcasted, and the
information they provide you is
considered non-control information,
meaning they don't control you with the
information that they produce. The other
two places where we could receive
weather reports are on AWS and ASOS
frequencies. AWOS stands for automated
weather observing system and ASOS stands
for automated surface observing system.
The main difference in these two
services is that ASOS is operated by
Noah. But the way pilots use these are
the same. So I'm going to group these
two together. Let's take a look beneath
the shelf of the class Charlie here at
Adamsfield. This is North Little Rock
Municipal Airport. And down here in the
information section, we'd find the
frequency that we tune in in order to
listen to the AWAS. Notice this little
code 3PT beside the word AWAS. This
tells us what's available on this
frequency. You can find this chart in
the AIM in section 7. But as you can see
here, this particular AWAS, I can get
wind, visibility, temperature, and due
point, alimter, density, altitude, cloud
and ceiling, the precipitation type, and
it can let me know if there's
thunderstorms in the area. One thing
that you really need to know about this
system is that these are usually fully
automated. Sensors collect all the data
and then a computer reads it out to you.
And these systems give you a reading
every minute. And that's a pretty good
advantage over the ADIS system. But the
advantage of the ADIS is that a human
being looks over it before the broadcast
goes out. With that in mind, AWS and
ASOS systems can sometimes be corrected
by humans, but typically we're relying
on sensors and computers to give us good
information. And let's not too quickly
forget what happened in the movie
Terminator. Let's tune the radio in to
North Little Rock's AWAS.
North Little Rock Municipal Airport.
Automated weather observation 2 3 5 8
Zulu. Wind 5 0 at 6 knots. Visibility
more than 1.
Sky condition clear below 12,000.
Temperature 1 C. Due point -7 C.
Altimeter 3 0 4 1 in of mercury
remarks. Notice the pilots be aware of
deer and coyote wildlife in vicinity of
the runway.
Notice how this report is really similar
to the ADIS. Because of that, I'm not
going to go into a lot of detail here,
but I do want to point out one thing. If
the time in this recording is more than
a minute old, I start to get a little
bit concerned about how accurate this
report is. That's why a lot of pilots
call this the one minute weather. And if
you're inbound for the field and you're
talking with ATC, this is the verbiage
you should use.
Little Rock approach Skyhawk 1 2 3 4
Papa 12 nautical miles to the east 4500
inbound for north Little Rock with the
one minute weather.
I hope you enjoyed this video today. If
you did, please smash that like button
and don't be done studying. Try this
video next. You're going to love it and
it's going to make you a better pilot.
We'll see you. Aircraft calling safe
position.
[groaning]